our union is based on the tripod of
democracy human rights and the rule of
law and through the European history we
know that if we abandon one of the legs
of the tripod the whole tripod will
topple never can one be used against the
other if we do not want to revisit the
horrible mistakes Europeans have made in
our past Europe is ultimately an idea
and a promise that it is possible to
overcome age-old antagonisms
that it is possible to live together
trade together work together in freedom
and peace freedom freedom is what so
many people fought for the European
Union based on the rule of law democracy
and respect for human rights is the
concrete expression of the will of
freedom of 500 million Europeans
[Music]